Karim Sader bonjour
Bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur RTL France 26
personnes donc accusé d'avoir participé
à la à l'assassinat de Jamal un procès
qui reprend aujourd'hui un procès sont
les accusés donc ça
oui c'est un procès par contumace de
toute façon ce n'est pas de temps le
déroulement de la procédure à
faire mais c'est surtout le fait que les
projecteurs soit sur la personne et de
cette absolument horrible à faire
3 ans
donc c'est encore une fois comme un
poulet dans le pied que se retrouve à
traîner un peu
aux yeux du monde alors tu tentes
par-dessus tout de faire oublier tout là
et de donner à l'autre image
modernisation du royaume et sont
différents des événements parler le
prochain par exemple tournoi de Formule
1 qui
se rendre en Arabie Saoudite
dans
le monde
du renseignement américain
on peut s'attendre à quoi finalement
les principaux indicateurs
ne soit pas présent contenu du fait
qu'on sait très bien que les intérêts
géopolitique opprimé sur la justice à on
pense très bien
et très bien que les dés sont joués
quand à la procédure juridique en a même
mais en revanche
c'est plus sur le plan de médiatique
cela fait du mal au prince héritier
parce que
il est ton nom en images
une affaire aussi embarrassante pour la
Turquie parce que on se souvient les
relations entre la Turquie et l'Arabie
Saoudite dans le siège de cette affaire
quelques semaines après les relations
sont tendu est-ce que aujourd'hui il n'y
a pas le fait aussi que la Turquie et
c'est un rapprochement avec l'Arabie
Saoudite de ménage et ses relations
oui bien sûr il y a il y a 7 aspects qui
est la Turquie a une carte précieuse en
main
depuis le départ il était pas au courant
de tout pour avoir réussi enfin en tout
cas pour avoir laissé un assassinat se
faire sur leur territoire et surtout ils
ont tous les enregistrements dans le
consulat donc c'est
bien
[Musique]
quand il s'agit de
en ce moment
[Musique]
récemment
apparaître un
joueur qui est
plus qui
va être abattu dans ce jeu
au niveau international finalement c'est
vraiment
par exemple
oui je pense que elle va continuer à
utiliser
on imagine déjà mal totalement étranger
donc c'est une affaire qui vient
toujours remettre en question
et sa volonté de draguer l'Occident et
Donkey Kong à faire et d'autres affaires
également
l'affaire avec
lui
merci beaucoup Karim Sader pour votre
éclairage ce matin sur RT France je
rappelle vous êtes politologue
spécialiste du Moyen-Orient et du Golfe
Persique